he was nuts if we're not waking up in
the morning and said oh let me be broke
that's just a winning attitude why are
you hanging around with that guy
rainbows after storms you can't fall on
the floor and confidence will have a
success its confidence in self-esteem
the minute you think you know everything
at that moment you know nothing if I
gave the guy a fish he did for a day
he's an American financial literacy
entrepreneur and businessman he's the
founder chairman and CEO of the
nonprofit organization hope he served as
vice-chair on the US presidents Advisory
Committee for financial literacy he's
John Hope Bryant and here are his top
ten rules for success people say I'm
nuts and and that's a compliment because
I said that Steve Jobs was nuts
they said the Ted Turner was nuts I said
the Bill Gates was nuts
they said that my hero dr. Martin Luther
King jr. was nuts
we tell you what I'll take it people not
wake you up in the morning and said oh
let me be broke let me be poor and
ignorant let me be stupid let me let me
go into some deep uncomfortable waters
because I thought I understood poverty
some you know if you ever noticed I'm
black I grew up in South Central LA in
common California my tell you little bit
about my story but I actually thought
dr. Franklin and I was poor I now
realize I wasn't there's a difference
between being broken being poor to be
broke as economic but to be poor is a
disabling frame of mind and a depressed
condition of your spirit and you must
vow never ever ever to be poor again
I was talking dr. Franklin and others
and there was an experiment that he was
telling me about about some gentlemen
who were very well-meaning they're going
out hanging out with Holmes people to
try to you know relate to their
experience and they dressed like I'm
they act like they walk like I'm I talk
like they live life but the legitimate
people who are homeless knew that these
were instigators they knew that they
were not homeless why the tinkle was
still in the eye the hope was still in
their eyes I can give a homeless guy a
million dollars he'll be broke at six
months with the best of intentions
because nothing changed here and here
the work capital comes from a Latin root
word copy toss it means knowledge in the
head it doesn't even mean money told you
the issue is confidence but if I can
make you immune to failure not ashamed
of to trip and fall if you can have an
opportunity to have somebody invest in
you at an early age believe in yourself
have some some experience with free
enterprise with starting something on
your own but believing in yourself
pursuing it no matter what the outcome
an entrepreneurial mindset works whether
you're running a household whether
you're running a community center or
city government or your own life or your
own business
it is the can-do empowerment based what
I'm for not what I'm against mindset
that I will do anything from from
anywhere for any purpose at any time
that is unique to an entrepreneur that
is always reimagining everything and
creating solutions that's just a winning
attitude about life so here's a rule
where you talk without being offensive
listen without being defensive but
always leave even your adversary with
their dignity because that you don't
spend the rest of life trying to make
you miserable so help people win when
George Bush was in office my friends oh
why are you hanging around with that guy
he's the president
and and so I got that I talked to him
for a while and I got an assign as the
executive order around financial
literacy and I'm and I'm proud that he
did that and by the way I've honored
that to serve now three presidents from
both political parties Republicans and
and Democrats I serve Obama today but I
think we need to talk to everybody and
you never know your friends going to be
and she'll make friends everywhere and
and and in people who you I think least
expect to provide the sort of leadership
you need but maybe the ones that
actually end up doing it so make friends
everywhere you can I grow without
legitimate suffering you cannot grow
without legitimate suffering rainbows
follow stormy last book the favorite
favorite chapter was lost creates
leaders nobody welcome to the morning
said I want to start a Cancer Foundation
people start Cancer Foundation's are
people whose lives of an impact that
somehow by cancer rainbows after storms
I was homeless for six months of my life
and what did that teach you you can't
fall on the floor that I had to redefine
failure is going from redefine success
actually can go and tell you to fail you
without loss of enthusiasm
but I had to learn to do for myself that
phd's were good but pH dues were better
and it and it made me get real with
success and failure in my life and made
me resilient you know for you to sit
here and ask me questions or to approach
me this morning takes personal
confidence we either look me in the eye
right now takes personal confidence
we'll have a success it's confidence and
self-esteem but if you're poor you've
been beaten down you've been depressed
you lack hope so it's very interesting
that very the very thing you need as the
first the first option to be successful
you actually don't have by virtue of the
fact that you've been in this poor
environment and and so today my life
makes sense but but the minute you think
you know everything at that moment you
know nothing and so I was in India and I
was teaching a course on leadership in
India and I had gone in this university
and I spoke there and after I left I got
back to the to the to the hotel and I
realized I didn't have my wallet and so
I called the hotel and I said can you
please bring the car back they have my
wallet and they said I'm sorry sir we
don't have a car that was a taxi we used
and so they try calling the taxi company
nobody answered the phone they tried
again and nobody answered the phone and
I became a little cynical
I went from hopeful to skeptical to
cynical I start thinking the worst of
people and of course I said with my my
wallet is gone by midnight they called
and said we're still trying he's not
answering the phone the taxi cab driver
but at 2:00 in the morning they called
and said he answered his phone his phone
was off he's coming back to your hotel
with your wallet so I get dressed and I
run down stairs and a man meets me in
the bellmen translates in for me in
India in the dye election and I asked
the man what ha and I get my wallet and
everything is in my wallet everything my
passport my money my credit cards is all
there and I reach into my wallet in
there 70 dollars us I asked a man
through a translator what do you make a
month he says about 2500 rupees which
about at that time which is about $70
u.s. so I reach out and I say let me
give this $70 to you this is my way of
saying thank you and the man says no I
said no I don't think you understand
have one month salary for you I want to
say thank you his $70 and the man says
to the translator no and I said there
must be a translation problem here I'm
talking about paying you I'm talking
about giving you a month's worth of your
salary one more time he said and this
time he became a little visibly younger
he said angry he said I told you no I
didn't bring you your wallet because I
wanted a reward I brought you your
wallet because it's your wallet now this
may not sound like an incredible story
but think would have happened if I had
lost my wallet in a taxi in New York
City or a big city anywhere in the world
think about what the chances of me
getting my wallet back think about it
and be honest with yourself now this is
a slum so they call it in India so I
said to the man what can I do to be
thankful to you what can I do to say
thank you he said well the next time
you're in India come to my house and
have tea be my friend who sometimes when
you give you get sometimes whatever goes
around comes around and so Lubuntu as
they say in South Africa Ubuntu I am me
because you are you I didn't give that
man a thing he gave me a sense of
purpose he let me understand that
there's hoping people and that you can
believe in the humanity and the decency
of people in some times you will just do
things because the right thing to do
what have we all just made a commitment
to be someone's friend to show up in
their house and have key or better to
invite them into our house and make that
connection you gain more by giving you
get more by building you learn more by
listening we have a chance and an
opportunity to change the world because
nobody changes in good times people only
change in bad times no one changes when
they're comfortable they change when
they're uncomfortable we have a chance
now to change the world
and so here's my question as I wrap up
and I'm now going to come right to you
I'm going to ask you what kind of bird
do you want to be but I want you to
answer in your own dialect in your own
word but I'm going to start with
something easy and you got to repeat
after me I can change the world
I will be the change in the world you
guys sound really weak talk like I got
passion in your life talk oh my god
remember now you're honorary black
people you got to have some soul I'm
gonna ask you one more time I am
somebody I can change the world
I am I question what kind of bird do you
want to be no no sad would passion what
kind of bird do you want to be give them
a round of applause
so if I gave the guy a fish he'd eat for
a day okay but I taught him how to fish
not only is he eating for a day now
leaves his family eating his employees
are eating he's actually now teaching
other people how to eat and that ripple
effect that financial literacy is the
only philanthropic or charitable or
nonprofit activity that has leverage
that uses leverage once I teach you
you're never untaught you know once your
rubber band is expanded it doesn't go
back to the same size as expanded so
your understanding your appreciation for
life is different and that is the
special sauce to me that is what makes
this transformational in its potential
but I was a dancer on Soul Train okay I
am an American Bandstand Wow
they were they were they taped across a
hall from each other so I've never done
this publicly is there any music let me
get out the way
yeah please I hope none of my
shareholders are watching my my
investment they go down
no no I mean something with your Beach -
that is far too that actually might have
been like the theme music for so trainer
you know I don't have to do this so you
you didn't you can just cut that you can
just cut the music altogether what up i
don'ti don't look I don't got any palm
something's not one of us
I'm sure I'll be paying the price for
that later luck luckily that show kept
me in shape and I stay in shape so I'll
have minimal pain
I'm sure that's pretty unique amongst
your speakers that pretty much falls in
place with my life philosophy which is
take life seriously but don't take
yourself too seriously just have a light
touch so one of the diseases that we
have in this world of seriousness people
take themselves very serious and people
take themselves very serious and force
other people to offer suffer from this
disease of insecurity which is then
connected to Fader which is then tied to
how you treat other people thank you so
much for watching I made this video
because Bishop asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know which of John hopes Brian's top
10 rules meant the most to you had the
biggest impact leave a little comment
and I'll join the discussion thank you
so much for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon